We're on problem 71.
And they ask us, which fraction
is equivalent to this
thing, 3x over 5 divided by
x plus 4 over x plus 2?
Now the best way to do this,
let's simplify the denominator
first. So that's equal
to 3x over 5.
All of that over-- let's find
a common denominator.
The common denominator is 4.
So if we have a common
denominator of 4, x/4 is of
course x/4.
x/2 is the same thing
as 2x over 4.
So plus 2x over 4.
2x over 4 is the same
thing as x/2.
And now if you divide by a
certain fraction, that's the
same thing as multiplying
buy its inverse.
So this is going to be equal to
3x over 5 times the inverse
of this, times 4
over x plus 2x.
Let's see what we could do.
Well we could factor
out an x here.
So this becomes x
times 1 plus 2.
Actually, 1 plus 2 is 3.
I should have said x plus
2x is equal to 3x.
I should have done.
That's silly, I shouldn't
have done that.
I should have said x plus
2x is equal to 3x.
My bad.
Anyway, 3x and 3x cancel out.
Numerator and denominator.
And you're left with 4/5.
And that's choice C.
It's getting late.
Next question.
72.
Let me copy and paste this.
Word problems, it's good to
parse these together.
All right, OK, a pharmacist
mixed some 10% saline solution
with some 15% saline solution to
obtain 100 milliliters of a
12% saline solution.
How much of the 10% saline
solution did the pharmacist
use in the mixture?
OK, so 10% and 15%.
So let T equal the amount
of 10% percent.
And let's say that F is equal to
the amount of 15% solution.
I picked T for ten,
F for fifteen.
OK, so the amount of 10%
solution plus the amount of
15% solution, that has to
equal 100 milliliters.
I'll assume we're dealing
in milliliters.
That equals 100.
And then, how much saline are
we going to end up with?
So, if we have the 10% saline
solution, however much saline
we have, how much saline
is that going to
contribute to the whole?
Well it's 10% saline, so we're
going to contribute 10% of
that as saline.
So 10% times the amount of 10%
solution tells me how much
saline I'm contributing.
Plus 15% times the amount of
the 15% saline solution I'm
contributing.
This is the amount of saline
from that solution.
And that equals what?
Now this is interesting.
You end up with a 12%
saline solution.
100 milliliters of a 12%
So how much saline total am I
going to have when I mix it
all together?
I had 100 milliliters.
It's a 12% saline solution.
So that means 12% of this 100
milliliters is saline.
So that equals 12.
There's 12 milliliters
of saline.
With this much contributed from
the 10% solution and that
much contributed from
the 15% solution.
Let's see what we can do.
So now we have two linear
equations and two unknowns.
We're ready to solve.
What do they want to know?
They want to know how much of
the 10% saline solution.
So the best thing, we want to
cancel out the F's somehow and
solve for T.
So let's multiply this top
equation times minus 0.15,
because I want to cancel
this out with this.
So let's do that.
If you multiply times minus
0.15, we end up with minus
0.15T minus 0.15F is
equal to minus 15.
So we add these two equations,
0.1 plus minus 0.15 that's
minus 0.05T.
These two cancel out.
It's equal to 12 minus
15 is minus 3.
OK, we can multiply both sides
by negative 1, you get plus
0.05 times T is equal to 3.
Sorry, I'm getting messy here.
So if you divide both sides by
0.05, you have T is equal to 3
divided by 0.05.
0.05, that's the same
thing is 1/20.
So this is equal to 3 times
20, which is equal to 60.
So we contributed 60 milliliters
of the 10% percent
saline solution.
So T is equal to 60 and
that's choice A.
And this is a little bit
confusing, because you're like
what variable do I use for the
10% solution and how do I set
up a second equation?
And a good place to start is to
say, oh well they want to
know how much of the 10%
saline solution did the
pharmacist use, so let me
set that is a variable.
Let me set another
variable for the
other type of solution.
If I add them together I have
to get 100 milliliters.
And the tricky part was just
probably figuring out how much
saline did each of the
solutions contribute?
And then when you add that
up, it equals 12
milliliters of saline.
Anyway, next question.
73.
Andy's average driving speed
for a 4 hour trip was
45 miles per hour.
During the first 3 hours he
drove 40 miles per hour.
What was his average speed for
the last hour of his trip?
OK, so distance is equal
to rate times time.
OK, so his total for a 4 hour
trip was 45 miles per hour.
Or you could say rate is equal
to distance divided by time.
Just divide both sides
of that by time.
So they said, the average
driving speed for a 4 hour
trip was 45 miles per hour.
So 45 miles per hour is equal
to the distance he traveled
divided by his time.
Divided by 4 hours.
So we can figure out the
distance right off the bat.
So let's actually do that.
The distance is equal
to 4 times 45.
That's what?
It's equal to 180 miles.
Fair enough.
They say during the first
3 hours, he drove
40 miles per hour.
What was his average speed for
the last hour of his trip?
So we just have to figure
out how much ground
did he have to cover?
So, during the first 3 hours,
he drove 40 per hour.
So how far did he go?
So that's a different distance,
that's just the
first 3 hours.
So the distance over the first
3 hours is equal to the rate
of the first 3 hours, it's equal
to 40, times the time,
times 3 hours.
So his distance over the first 3
hours is equal to 120 miles.
So how far did he have to travel
in that last hour?
Well, in the first 3 hours
he went 120 miles.
He went a total of 180 miles.
So his distance in that
last hour is going to
be 180 minus 120.
He had to go 60 miles
in that last hour.
So how fast did he go?
Well he went 60 miles in that
last hour, so he went
60 miles per hour.
Choice B.
So this might seem like a
complicated problem, and it is
a little tricky.
But it's all about distance
equals rate times time.
And then recognizing that you
could use this first statement
to figure out the total
distance he traveled.
You could use the second
statement to figure out how
far he traveled in the
first 3 hours.
And then you know how far he
had to travel in that last
hour, or essentially how
fast he had to travel.
Next question.
74.
One pipe can fill a tank
in 20 minutes.
So let's say pipe 1 its
rate is equal to
1 tank per 20 minutes.
That's how I like to write it.
That's what they told us.
One pipe can fill a tank in 20
minutes, while another takes
30 minutes to fill
the same tank.
So pipe 2, is equal to 1
tank per 30 minutes.
That's its rate.
Or 1/30 tank per minute.
This is 1/20 tank per minute.
Fair enough.
How long would it take the two
pipes together to fill it?
So their combined rate is
just both of these.
If you have both pipes going in,
you're going to have 1/20
tank per minute plus 1/60
tank per minute.
Let's see.
1/20 plus 1/60, common
denominator is 60.
1/20 is 3/60 plus 1/60 is
1/60 tanks per minute.
It's just adding fractions.
So that equals 4/60
tanks per minute.
4/60, that's 1/15 tanks
per minute.
Or you view this as equal to
one tank per 15 minutes.
So how long does it take
to fill one tank?
15 minutes.
Choice is C.
Oh I'm all out of time.
I'll see in the next video.